hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast circulating biomarkers
what matters for isolation of biomarkers
from liquid biopsy samples presented by
dr. Vorenus from a global product
manager at kya Jiang I'm Suzy Valdez of
Lab roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
kaijin hydron serves more than 500,000
customers around the globe all seeking
insights from the building blocks of
life DNA RNA and proteins they deliver
samples to insight solutions for
molecular testing propelling hyejung
customers from start to finish to unlock
new insights before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located on the lower left of
your presentation window and type those
questions into the box that appear on
the screen well answer as many as we can
during the presentation also notice that
you're viewing the presentation in a
slide window to enlarge that window
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
hearing or seeing this presentation
click on the support button at the top
right or use that Q&A button to let us
know you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits
please click on the button and a lower
left to follow and process those credits
without further ado please join me in
welcoming dr. Luo Venus wrong I will now
turn the presentation over to our
speaker welcome dr. Shrum
thank you so much for the very nice
introduction Susie and thanks to
everyone for joining this session today
I want to talk a little bit about
circulating biomarkers and what matters
for the isolation of these biomarkers
from liquid biopsy samples kinds and
products that I will be talking about
today shown here are intended for
molecular biology applications these
products are not intended for the
diagnosis prevention or treatment of the
disease this is the agenda for today and
I really want to set the stage for
giving you a short introduction to
liquid biopsy and remind everyone of
what this technique is about here is a
common definition of liquid biopsy the
application of minimally invasive
techniques that can be used to help
detect molecular biomarkers and body
fluids which may allow for improved
diagnosis and treatment of cancer as
well as other diseases so this
definition already tells you that liquid
biopsy is a minimally invasive
techniques and holds really a great
potential for diagnosis and treatment of
cancer patients and other patients in
the future the advantages of liquid
biopsy in comparison to the classical
tissue biopsy are listed here on this
slide
first of all liquid biopsy has a lot of
advantages when it comes to sample
availability it's much easier to take a
blood draw from a patient or to take a
urine sample from a patient than to
obtain a tissue biopsy also the process
simplicity is advantageous for liquid
biopsy compared to the tissue biopsy the
processing speed of the sample also is
better for liquid biopsy with liquid
biopsy you can really early detect or
even screen for diseases like cancer
whereas with a tissue biopsy usually the
diagnosis of the patient has happened
before and afterwards a tissue biopsy is
taken to really diagnose
and characterize the cancer disease
monitoring is another advantage of
liquid biopsy because you have so easy
access to liquid biopsy samples you can
constantly monitor the disease
progression that is especially important
again for cancer patients liquid biopsy
also has an advantage when we talk about
cost effectiveness so taking a blood
draw or taking a urine sample or another
body fluid sample it's a lot easier than
taking a tissue biopsy which usually
requires a small surgery in terms of the
sensitivity there is still a little bit
of discussion in the field and the
sensitivity of these technologies
clearly depend also on the analytical
methods that I use however now
especially with methods like
next-generation sequencing or digital
PCR the sensitivity is really high
enough to detect all sorts of mutations
from the liquid biopsy sample so there
is more and more research being done on
liquid biopsy and people move away from
from the classical tissue biopsy so to
say there is a lot of potential also to
then look into circulating biomarkers so
circulating biomarkers are the biomarker
molecules that you can obtain from a
liquid biopsy sample first of all
circulating biomarkers is a field that
is really well funded
especially exosome research is one of
the best funded research areas at the
moment and there is a lot of
publications coming out focusing on
circulating biomarkers and people are
finding new biomarkers essentially every
week this is also highlighted here by
the NOAA right graph which shows you the
increase of publications from pubmed on
the topic of liquid biopsy and
circulating biomarkers and as I already
mentioned we now already have the right
tool box in hand with sensitive essays
like next-generation sequencing or
digital PCR to really analyze these
liquid biopsies
samples and uh circulating biomarkers
within these samples in detail and
understand the full potential of this
new sample type however there are also a
lot of challenges associated with the
analysis of circulating biomarkers
usually these types of analytes are only
present in very low sample
concentrations that is especially true
for circulating RNA obtained from a
liquid biopsy there is also still a lot
of analytical errors that can be caused
by sample handling and this is linked to
the fact that there are no SOPs or
standard working procedures in place
already
just because liquid biopsy is such a new
area and people are still actively
working on on defining such that
standards excuse me when we look at
liquid biopsy there is really a broad
variety of different biomarker types
that can be investigated the types of
analytes that are commonly studied are
listed here on this slide circulating
selphie nucleic acids is probably the
type of analyte that's been studied the
most and liquid biopsy contexts in the
past years however also exosomes as well
as circulating tumor cells are becoming
more and more important for the analysis
of new biomarkers I want to talk a
little bit more about exosomes and also
focus on circulating RNA biomarkers in
the third row of this presentation so
exosomes are small vesicles that are
excreted by all cells of the body
including tumor cells subsequently they
can be found in all bio fluids that can
be obtained from the human body
extracellular vesicles are exosomes our
cargo molecules and they play an
important role in cell to cell
communication they actually are found to
contain stable nucleic acids in fact all
sorts of nucleic acids that you can also
find in the normal cell so mRNA micro
RNA other regulatory
rnase as well as DNA proteins lipids and
all of these different analytes are in
fact protected from degradation by the
lipid bilayer that is let's say
surrounding the the exosome the
interesting point about exosomes and why
people study RNA from exosomes
is that the RNA contained within
exosomes provides a complete snapshot of
the transcriptome of the secreting cell
so again it's a minimally invasive way
to look at the expression changes that
are happening in a specific cell type
that you're interested in the contents
however really varies also depending on
the physiological or pathological
conditions so similar to other features
if you compare the exosomes from one
human to another they will be very
different depending on on these
conditions cell 3 RNA is extremely
important because extracellular vesicles
are also secreted by tumor cells so the
RNA that's contained within these
extracellular vesicles in fact can be
used to detect tumor specific mutations
these tumor specific mutations like
fusion genes for example are only
detectable at the RNA level so looking
at the DNA level you will not be able to
find such fusion genes you really need
to look into RNA as a nucleic acid tag
there is also a lot of micro RNA content
within these exercise and we know that
the micro RNA content that is within
exosomes is different and very specific
to that compared outside to the micro
RNA content outside of exosomes and
there is a lot of publications that are
focusing on RNA in the context of Evie
research and more and more
so although past research has been
focusing more on the cell-free DNA side
RNA analysis especially in excellent
research is becoming more and more
popular and more and more people are
looking into this in more detail this is
just a reminder of what RNA biomarkers
are present in liquid biopsy samples and
where they are typically found within a
liquid biopsy sample so mRNA is usually
only contained inside of extracellular
vesicles because this is where mRNA is
in fact protected protected by the lipid
bilayer long non-coding RNAs are also
exclusively present inside of
extracellular vesicles again because
they are protected there for micro RNA
it's a little bit different micro RNAs
in liquid biopsy samples are either
within extracellular vesicles or they
are bound to protein complexes like the
other two proteins so if they are all
sort of thing circles they are protected
by protein complexes or they are
protected within exercise let's talk a
little bit more about what matters for
sample collection and disruption so this
is a classical RNA workflow from sample
to inside going through all the
different steps that you have to
consider if you want to do a gene
expression analysis based on RNA in any
satellite in fact and I want to remind
everyone here that each of these steps
is very important and that a certain
amount of detail needs to be paid
towards each of these individual steps
actually the same applies for liquid
biopsy samples that we are focusing on
today so let's talk a little bit more
about the sample collection and also
sample disruption
I was already mentioning that the RNA
that's relevant for a liquid biopsy
analysis is in fact well protected
so mRNA is encapsulated and protected
within extracellular Vesey
girls and exercise and extracellular
microRNAs are either contained within
exosomes or loaded into high-density
protein complexes like our go-to again
this makes them very inaccessible for
rnases and they are thus prevented from
RNA degradation the challenges of RNA
isolation from liquid biopsy samples are
more on the side of low RNA content and
also a high inhibitor amount that can be
present in serum and plasma samples
specifically which can inhibit the
downstream assay so stabilization of of
blood cells is in fact more a topic for
a cell-free DNA than it is for RNA
because the RNA that you are interested
in in the liquid biopsy context is
usually very well protected and
preserved for DNA the story is a little
bit different because when cells undergo
apoptosis they release tree DNA from the
nucleus and this Gideon a is diluting
the cell-free DNA signal that he would
be interested in a liquid biopsy context
so stabilization of blood cells is very
important for cell free DNA analysis
it's less of a concern for RNA analysis
from liquid biopsy samples what is also
very important is that you take a
detailed look and into your pre
analytical work flow we know that a lot
of the differences in in results or
inconsistencies and results that are
obtained very often stem already from
the pre analytical processing of the
samples so here are some considerations
for the isolation of intech exosomes and
EVs as well as their content
first of all quite some background can
come from cellular nucleic acids that
are released when cells undergo
apoptosis so what we usually recommend
is to do an upfront filtrations that was
probations that has indicated here on
the left side in this little pictogram
which removes background from cellular
RNA that can be diluting the desired
sample then another question that we are
very often asked is what kind of sample
time should you be looking at should you
especially when we talk about serum or
plasma people are asking is it better to
use serum or better to use plasma based
on our experience we would say that
plasma is a better sample type to
analyze the nucleic acid content of
liquid biopsy samples but there is also
reasons for choosing a serum really
dependent also on what sample type might
be available for you and for your
research
however it's very important that
throughout your experiment or your
analysis you are consistent in the
sample type that you are using so don't
mix serum and plasma samples and avoid
this if it's possible another aspect to
consider is the blood collection device
from our experience we know that most of
the blood collection tubes are suitable
for exosome isolation and subsequent RNA
isolation and profiling
however again here it's important that
you ensure to use the the same blood
collection device or blood tubes
throughout your experiment and for all
your analysis so let's move into RNA
purification topics again here it's
important to not just look into RNA
isolation but also QC of the RNA as this
is an integral part of every good RNA
experiment to look into the RNA quality
after the isolation when we talk about
RNA isolation from plasma or serum
samples again the very small amount of
RNA especially EXO's normal RNA are
probably the largest challenge for any
isolation method that's in fact why we
have dedicated solutions here at
cryogens specifically designed for low
amounts of our and
or specifically for EXO soma RNA in
terms of starting volume from micro RNA
as it's a little bit higher abundant
than mRNA it's usually sufficient to
start with 200 microliters of plasma or
serum you can use higher volumes however
this also increases your risk of getting
inhibitions in your downstream and then
later on for mRNA as it's usually only
contained within exosomes the abundances
are much lower so here we recommend to
at least start with one milliliter of
serum or plasma to have them sufficient
amounts of RNA molecules mRNA molecules
to go into a deeper analysis of gene
expression differences contamination is
especially a problem for serum or plasma
samples as especially plasma has a lot
of protein contaminants but also
contaminants like anticoagulants heparin
or EDTA can interfere with downstream
assays so here it's very important to
efficiently remove such contaminants to
avoid inhibition in the downstream as a
also another point that I forgot to
mention is the presence of rnases rnases
are degrading your RNA and are thus
lowering the RNA integrity which can be
an issue to make a significant statement
or a good analysis of your sample in
your downstream essay so as soon as you
release your RNA in a liquid biopsy
sample from its protection either by
lysing exosomes or by lysing the
proteins that are binding microRNAs it's
also important to inactivate rnases at
the same time what is usually a very
good way to inactivate rnases and also
to to remove contaminants is a phenyl
chloroform step that's why a lot of our
kids are still containing a fee no clue
step however we have recently launched a
new mini z0 plasma advance kit which
uses an alternative to phenol which is a
combination of buffers RPL and RP p1 is
meant for the lysis of proteins and
exosomes and the inactivation of rnases
and the second one is then to
precipitate the proteins and
contaminants and remove them from the
sample in the second step you are then
taking the supernatant and you go into
the typical spin color based protocols
from from hydrogen so here you really
have the advantage to get rid of the
phenol you don't need to do a phase
separation step and in fact you don't
need to work under the hood anymore
these kids are also including what we
call the UCP columns and I'm going to
talk a little bit more about that in a
second and what exactly it stands for in
terms of the performance we are here
comparing now this new kit and its
performance to our Negus see me and easy
serum plasma kit and we see that despite
getting rid of the phenol step and
replacing this step we are not making
any compromises on micro RNA years as
you can see here by the CT values on the
y-axis here are shown for three
different donors so you are getting an
easier protocol and you don't have to
compromise on micro RNA yields or
quality this new kit is also able to
efficiently NIH's exosomes as you can
see by this graph here we are looking at
a comparison between the new kit and our
I XOR an easy easy on plasma kit XOR and
easy kids are specifically isolating
total RNA from exosomes so for those
micro RNAs that are known to be
primarily inside of exosomes
we see very similar yields between the
two kids for those micro RNAs that are
present outside of exosomes we see a
slightly better performance for the
music it compared to the XO or any
liquid and that's because XR and ez is
enriching for
so so more RNA specifically and it's
getting rid of the micro RNAs that are
outside of exercise let me tell you a
little bit more about the UCP column
concept so you see P stands for ultra
clean production and especially in the
days of next-generation sequencing
people are looking in an unbiased way at
the complete samples nucleic acid
content and with these analysis it
actually became obvious that
contaminations especially in the
microbiome context are coming up from
spin columns that's a fact of the spin
column membranes that a lot of providers
are using however this is then also
reducing the number of useful reads that
you get from your NGS experiments and
especially for a microbiome experiment
you can even get certain bias in your
results due to this contamination so
what now a lot of our columns are
undergoing is the UCP treatment so that
is a special production treatment which
ensures ultra clean outlets that are
only containing minimal contamination so
to say and significantly reduce the
amount of exogenous nucleic acids as you
can also see here by the lower graph
where we are comparing the current UCP
problems compared to accounts from from
other providers
I was already mentioning that RNA
quality control is an integral part of
every RNA isolation that you perform in
the lab and for liquid biopsy samples
it's especially challenging because the
amounts are low and you have a lot of
small RNAs within your samples the main
RNA quality parameters are listed here
usually people are looking into
quantities or how much or innate
have in my tube and at what
concentration is at present and do I
have enough material from my downstream
as they are the key questions here
another important quality parameter is
the purity so what is really invite you
do I have any contamination that could
be interfering with my downstream as me
and the third main parameter is the
integrity so does my RNA sample have the
correct size distribution that I would
expect or is there a lot of degradation
which might limit the types of analysis
that I can do with my RNA sample in the
downstream as I usually RNA quantity is
assessed through the absorbance at 260
nanometers and the classical
spectrophotometer
however for for this classical madam and
measurement you need to have a certain
amount of RNA in your Elliot if you have
very lowly concentrated RNA samples we
do not recommend to go with the
absorbance at 260 nanometers because
it's not a reliable method instead we
are usually recommended recommending
quantitative rt-pcr other methods that
are also used usually like the qubit
method for example also we're not
reliable in in our hands especially for
small rnas like microRNAs so usually for
liquid biopsy samples we are
recommending qrt-pcr as the method of
choice to assess the RNA quantity our
innate quality and purity is usually
determined by the ratio of 260
nanometers and 280 nanometers so this
ratio tells you how much contamination
you have in your sample and especially
how much protein you have another
measurement is the ratio between 260 to
230 which tells you how many impurities
like salts you have in your sample again
for liquid biopsy this is probably not
most reliable method because you usually
have very low amounts of sample here so
what you can do instead if you want to
understand how much contamination might
I have in my sample is to increase the
volume of your sample and look at
whether you get also more yields with
increased sample volumes if you do not
see a linear increase in your yield this
might be indicating that you have some
contamination in your sample what is
also important to remember is that
phenyl can have an effect on the UV
absorbance so this is probably then not
so relevant for liquid biopsy but it is
important for other RNA isolations that
you are performing in these graphs here
you see the absorbance spectrum of
phenol and you see that the phenyl
spectrum overlaps with the spectrum that
you would expect from pure RNA so if
you're using phenol in your workflow
it's very important to do careful
pipetting of the acquiesce phase and
avoid carryover of phenol because this
can falsify the RNA content and make you
think that you have an higher RNA
content in your sample than what's
actually present RNA integrity is
usually assessed through the Rin value
either through a bio analyzer or through
the Chi excel in instrument from kaijin
however also for limited samples like
cell free RNA this measurement is
usually not very trustworthy so what we
are here during our product development
using a lot is a it's looking at the
delta CT value between a random priming
mix and an oligo DT priming mix as you
see indicated on here and we're looking
at the delta CT value you can make
and estimation on how intact RNA is so
the larger the Delta city between the
random cran a mix and the oligo DT
primer mix the less intact your RNA
usually is I also want to talk a little
bit more about exosome isolation because
when you look into the exosome isolation
techniques that have been used today and
this is a graphic coming from a recent
publication there was a lot of different
methods that people are using today and
when I want to highlight here is that
all of these methods in fact have their
advantages and disadvantages and when I
see these days is that a lot of people
start to combine different methods
because just using one method is not
sufficient to isolate exosomes in the
desired quantity and quality we
encourage and have the actual easy kids
and we are actually here using the
technology that comes from the
colleagues of exosome Diagnostics that
uses an affinity based membrane to
purify exosomes
the advantage of these kids is that they
are very specific in the purification of
exosomes and extracellular vesicles they
efficiently removed protein contaminants
which is some of the issue that other
methods are having and you do not need
to buy any special or very expensive
equipment like an ultracentrifuge
so these kids are based on a spin column
and they require a normal centrifuge
that is usually present or or sitting in
the lab and if we are looking a little
bit more into what kind of exosome RNAs
we are detecting and how specific that
enrichment is we see that in the Elliott
that comes from the spin column we get
an enrichment of vesicle like RNA so RNA
is called micro RNAs that are associated
with vesicles and then we get a
depletion of those micro RNAs that are
more known to be outside of exercise we
also get a very good capture of like M
RNA toilets re mRNA targets that are
listed here on the right side this is
just a handful of targets that we looked
at here what you really see that we are
capturing all of these targets all of
these results are also published in a
publication from 2015 that we did
together with our colleagues from Exxon
DX and this publication is among the top
25 most cited articles in plus one this
article also then goes a little bit more
into comparing the performance of this
exosome RNA isolation technique with
ultra centrifugation and you see here
that these two techniques show very
comparable size distributions of the RNA
that's been isolated if you want to get
a little bit more information about this
technique and how it can be used also
then in a downstream as Leonid MGS we
have recently presented a poster at the
ICF meeting this year in Canada where we
are doing exosome and micro RNA
profiling of colorectal cancer patients
using the cryogenics are an easy kit for
isolation and then the Chiron chiastic
micro RNA library kit for small RNA
library preparation and I'm happy to
send you a copy of this one if that's
interesting for you so let me sum up and
slightly slowly move over to the press
questions so what I have been talking
about today is mainly what matters for
the sample stabilization disruption and
then RNA isolation and QC however
cryogen offers really a complete
portfolio of liquid biopsy solutions
also including a lot of analytical
essays
that I mentioned here in in the middle
as you can see we have a broad portfolio
of NGS solutions for cell free DNA EXO
somos RNA and suffering like RNA and
then also a complete portfolio of
analysis for circulating tumor cells and
recently we've added a portfolio for
circulating cell free DNA and RNA so
this workflow would allow you to Co
isolate DNA and RNA and then go
subsequently into next-generation
sequencing as an SI we also have a
complete suit of analyst analysis and
interpretation software tools that are
then supporting you in in your
bioinformatics analysis afterwards so
with that I'm at the end of this
presentation I thank you very much for
your attention and you have our contact
details here if you have any follow-up
questions or a feedback and with that
I'm looking forward to your questions
thank you
dr. Stromm thank you so much for your
informative presentation and your
important research we will now start the
live portion of the Q&A in our webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of your presentation
window type that question into the box
that appears on the screen and we'll
answer it so let's get started our first
question from our audience member dr.
strong is how much is DNA contamination
a problem for RNA analysis from liquid
biopsies okay thank you yeah this is a
really good question so DNA
contamination can come up in your NGS
analysis especially if you do a whole
transcriptome analysis this can be
sorted out by one phonetically so you
can remove the let's say background that
comes from DNA contamination but of
course you're reducing the number of
meaningful reads that you have in your
in your sample or in your NGS experiment
so that's why if people want to be
really on the safe side we do recommend
to do a an on column DNA's treatment and
we usually give the guideline in our
handbooks on how to remove DNA if if
that is of concern for our customers
thank you so much dr. strong we have one
more audience question today and that
question is we just say do you recommend
to ant analysis for gnosis for cell-free
RNA yeah this is another really good
question so for cell free RNA we usually
recommend to go with next-generation
sequencing assays there is a lot of
different options for SAS available
today you can either go into a more
targeted RNA sequencing approach but you
can also do the whole transcriptome x
profiling of your RNA another option is
to do a specific micro RNA profiling
that I was also mentioning in the poster
that I showed you so preparing a
specific micro RNA library and then
doing a that's a complete micro RNA
profiling of your samples is also
possible with NGS and for me that would
be the method of choice today it's now
affordable and and maximizes the
research questions that you can answer
with your data set
that's John thank you so much for your
information
do you have any closing remarks you'd
like to share with our audience today
yeah so I can tell you that personally I
am extremely thrilled and excited about
all these options that are now coming up
with liquid biopsy so I'm really curious
to see how this field is going to
develop in the future and I will
definitely stay tuned on what new
publications are coming up and and where
the field is developing thank you and
thank you so much dr. flomm and I'd like
to take the opportunity to think lab
roots and our sponsor cryogen for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again
bye-bye